I feel like I'm the king of the world
well Nicki Minaj aka the king of the
world might be retiring female rappers
have kind of been in the in the back you
know kind of we've been like the
sidekick for a long time and you know I
am NOT jasmine I am Aladdin she's always
been outspoken but this time Nicki sent
fans into a frenzy when she tweeted she
was done with music quote I've decided
to retire and have my family I know you
guys are happy now to my fans keep
repping me do it tails to death of me
now Nicki has since deleted at that
tweet and after fans went berserk she
clarified writing I'm still right here
still madly in love with you guys and
you know that in hindsight this should
have been a queen radio discussion and
it will be I promise you guys will be
happy no guests just us talking about
everything the tweet was abrupt and
insensitive I apologize that's always
the goal I always want to be great at
anything I do
it sounds like fans will get actual
answers soon but Nicki has made clear
she's prioritizing her relationship with
Kenneth petty in August
Nicki revealed they got a marriage
license and now it's only a matter of
time until they say I do
you